well we're back let's talk about what's
coming up so welcome to council geeks my
name is Nathaniel 8 and I am joined this
time by Paul Sorvino and writing daily
and we are going to do that thing that
we do sometimes and talk about what's
coming out over the next three months so
we're going to talk to July August
September not covering everything
basically talking about the geeky stuff
or stuff that I just kind of want to get
your reaction to first up on the 7th of
July we have spread man homecoming hmm
now I am so excited on this part of
reason I think I'm maintaining my
excitement if I unplugged myself from
the marketing of this that is a movie so
after I think it was maybe three
trailers ago they have the first one
that I watched him like I'm not certain
this is showing that the whole movie but
it feels like it might be and I don't
want to risk seeing anything else and
knowing any more than I already know and
for what I have heard trailers that have
come out since then have been even worse
in that regards in terms of laying out
the entire plot of the movie at this
point it feels like I'm going to see
this movie in spite of the marketing for
it
oh nothing again it's a thing where
nothing they have shown me has been bad
or has turned me off or set up radars
it's just what feels like in a short
amount of time being a volume of what
I've seen it is kind of inexplicable in
our with uh no III explained Sony this
year is it are they worried that
nobody's gonna see it or that they just
don't know what they're doing I don't
think you look it was bad indifferent
way we you look at how bad the marketing
campaign was on ghostbusters last year
yeah I think so many neat the fires
entire marketing departments I've done
with my veil did which is I just stayed
away I actually watched the first
trailer loved it loved the character
from Avengers and oh yeah and I'm like I
don't want to see you more exciting oh
they're gonna try to do so one fear that
I do have about this movie is the
director um like John watts like yeah um
so this guy he has no experience doing
anything of this scale unless you know
you know he basically has one movie
before the Sun was a critical something
not cop car yeah I was a dog Mia can
swim it looks it's a heavy fun in Kevin
hi you can't pick this guy we saw and
but not to be fair this is sort of good
marbles track record well not nothing
valley s marble either something really
mean spider-man is mark we've been
finding it they've been looking for
either in the small-time director of
soon know how to tell a good story on
the low-budget or television directors
will often have to do the exact same
thing but we don't necessarily have the
ego and the clouds to demand things yeah
so they get somebody that they can force
to work into their machine and they say
we will give you the budget and we will
take care of all of that production
stuff on the back end because we got our
house guys that do that
and so I think as long as this guy can
tell a good story with good characters
make them likable that's most of the job
at the esse do went from ever being
heard with cop cars that's what he
proved that you can do that that is
actually kind of become the blockbuster
thing that a lot of them are doing now
because honestly Colin Trevorrow didn't
have much stewards made before they
throw him into Jurassic world and we've
seen this go both ways you want to look
at things the way that it's gone the
best I will probably point to James Gunn
going from the small indie movies to
garden in the galaxies er you want to
point at the worst possible option
officious josh trank right so we've seen
it going both extremes but this does
seem to be the current thing and I
actually talked about this briefly on go
home Hollywood you're drunk now
available on the council and geeks
podcasting listen now before they're all
gone the week after that on the 14th is
the other movie that I've been avoiding
the last few trailers on which is a war
for the Planet of the Apes yes between
these two movies this really has become
my mantra once I decide I'm going to see
a movie I stop watching new trailers
because I don't want to moon for me if I
don't attention this season will be sure
I'll see everything they come out and
because
anyways I continue to watch these
trailers they do show a lot I don't feel
like I've seen the whole thing but I
feel like I've seen a lot and again it's
the case of everything I'm seeing I like
it makes me excited to see it that I'm
kind of like it's just it's a
double-edged sword because yeah they had
my money a long time ago yeah and July
14th if I'm reassigning already and I
haven't had a child at that point I'll
go see an opening that um sometime you
got any clothes they they had my money
as soon as I walked out of dawn of the
Planet Essure I'm like I am viable in on
images it has sort of quietly in a very
unassuming way become one of my favorite
franchises the of the past decade or sir
and I mean I think Caesar might be one
of the more captivating central
characters in the film I would say in
the last decade oh yeah like Andy
surfaces presence his presence perform
his art between movements are already
yeah yeah and I yeah I'm go see that
movie three times what what I love about
this franchise especially is that even
though it is a franchise and they and
they have left the door open for where
to go at the end of each one
it also is never felt like they're
holding back for the sequel it feels
like four and every story that they're
telling we go and see it and yes I know
there can and will be more but I feel
like everything that was that was going
to be done with this story it's all up
there some of the still shots of Caesar
are under these linens to a question
that's not really to this episode but
something that you consider that this
director is signed on to do the Batman
so when and if that ever happens which
yes at this point isn't going to happen
till 2019 at the earliest yeah but even
one that is that is his next project so
so there's there's two movies coming out
the the week after that that I want to
bring out the first one is one that in
terms of the subject matter is not one
that I normally bring up yet I still see
it coming up in geek circles because of
who's making it hmm and that's Dunkirk
oh yeah well that is historical
Christopher Nolan 1:00 p.m. yeah and
really awesome that's coming up this
month or July sorry
yeah yes well okay five weeks from -
yeah well by the time I get this out it
was Benny a Mike and IBM started Merry
Christmas
I know I knew that was coming I assumed
it was going to be a December release so
sorry
well in classic Christopher Nolan
fashion
he has not been inundated us with 50
million variants of the trailer I just
remember seeing a teaser while ago about
it
and honestly what if Christopher Nolan's
doing I'm gonna go see yeah you know I'm
not excuse me I'm not sure if I was
going to rush out into the theater to
see it only just because it's it's
subject matter that I don't need it bad
but doesn't inherently call to me much
me now without his involvement so I
don't depending on what's going on my
life at that point in the mall that
might not be enough to give me the right
I was beer it'll go on my to-do list
along with 50,000 other things but if
announced the Army is forcing your back
to the sea you might go see it oh yes
yes under under the under those
circumstances I would I would take the
the role of Chamberlain and I would tap
out a little bit I would get some ground
raising the stakes on this review whole
phrase different sorry okay well beat
the other one coming out that same
weekend is valerian in the city of a
thousand planets I don't know what that
is that is another game no no it's a
comic book apparently to European comic
book so this is the latest space opera
offering from Luke Poisson and it being
I'm not sure if it was made with this
intent but it certainly being marketed
and hyped as a spiritual successor to
the fifth at once yeah um I'm a huge
sci-fi guy I'm not going to go through
this in the theater unless there is some
crazy hype around it I'm going to put
Nazis pressure you walk in that door so
is you know I don't know
that's going to be our new measure if
the Nazis we're backing you into the
city because your business is up if it
can strike the same balance that death
ailments truck which was this really
Razors Edge between epic space fantasy
and camp if they can straight the same
bounds that might work but setting the
Fifth Element I just look at it just
looks like the kind of thing where they
literally every vaguely sci-fi things
they just don't Fisher screw it up there
and it doesn't feel like a lot of rhyme
or reason is behind it and I can like it
to a certain extent as we can give you a
bonkers world but eventually it still
needs to feel cohesive like guarding the
galaxy managers are a lot of stuff up
there but it feels cohesive I look at
these trails I'm like that feels like
even more stuff with even less rhyme or
reason on US tour just is no favors yeah
you're not the one I did not make about
money for video yeah well he knows mice
excels and we want to contribute Nevin
where you seeing it yeah I'll do know it
it's 650 now it went up okay I saw I saw
a matinee of Wonder Woman alive yeah
especially a crappy feeder visit where
that it really is really nice we a lot
of our local 3 3 theatres this high next
digital 3d thing fad passing right on
the 28th of July you guys might not have
heard this one or this one yet but um
atomic blonde oh yeah but Charlie sir
yeah yeah though this this is from one
of the two directors of the first John
Blake movie basically one of the what
made John with two and the other one
went and made John wick female versions
and I saw a teaser that was they
basically just like a two minute long
choreographed sightseeing anodd
stairwell like daredevil or something
like well yeah it would be really really
good
and just from seeing the other thing
guys I wanted to see this movie like I
still haven't seen you know the John
with movies in their bowels don't you
think not around here I'm yeah weather
so here's the downsides of three the
locals are retreating at theater but
they're still not
on my radar but this under other
circumstances I might make an attempt to
see I will not travel to go see this I
saw the teaser it looked interesting
I've seen some of the still images that
come out of it looks fine this is
definitely a Netflix for me that's right
this is one that if it comes out local I
will see I probably wouldn't travel you
know to go see it but I the action
output of these guys I'm like you guys
just keep making movies like this I will
keep seeing them and you should be very
happy for it so that same weekend you're
getting the epic the legendary so much I
disability anticipated release of the
emoji movie oh I'm so glad you brought
this man who greenlit this here so there
was a meeting yeah there was a meeting
where somebody came in with a script or
an idea and they're like you know what
we should do we should make a movie
about the emojis and somebody feels like
yeah - great idea
and this area towards check and then
from that point forward this they went
for why right you're cool thought this
was coming I every everything about this
film makes me angry
I actually I want to stop using emojis
myself out of our personal protest not
only that but what I can see there's not
an original a single original idea in
this film and it seems to be just
cribbing jokes from other not even good
films and I hope it dies in the theater
if you're on your own thing is
envisioning the pitch and everything
there's a light you were talking about
something else but there's a line that
it's [ __ ] I have that I've loved
these they regard as a great idea bring
me my seed code
[Laughter]
[Music]
I wanted to bring that back and I loved
that committed so much um at this point
women when the movie first got announced
I rolled my eyes and then I also checked
myself and said you rolled your eyes in
the lego movie too
but then the trailer came out that and I
thought thanks actually could continue
rolling my eyes after that I felt like
in the wake of the lego movie being
great because it is I had to go I need
to at least wait till a trailer
I can't dismiss this on concept alone I
have to be sure that they didn't come up
with some angle that makes it work and
it doesn't look like it did so now I can
dismiss it now I can just all right I'm
going on August 4th the Dark Tower
so it's Matthew McConaughey Idris Elba
but the thing that I worry about with
random directors is the they tend to
load the editing process you can get
really blown in films from writer
directors because they think they need
everything there now I'm being overly
general I know but um well yeah here's
got a template to work from the image it
does and I actually think that's bad oh
okay and the reason I think that that is
this Steven is notoriously difficult to
adapt to them hmm
and the Dark Tower even more so because
the property is essentially one giant
inside joke it assumes in many ways that
you've read everything else that Stephen
King has written so now tight so it is I
go ahead before you epic our guests are
you aware because of the nature of the
narrative it is actually a sequel until
I am aware of that
okay I have wanted to see it are
terribly my entire adult life I just
worried that I don't know who in the
world would be talented enough to
actually tell the story well without
losing the audience and so I'm very
trepidatious I also think that the
marketing have been almost non-existing
and every until maybe about two weeks
ago yeah and I think they're worried too
and so the I'm not sure yes something
I'm not sure if it actually speaks to
the quality of the film I think they
have something that they don't know how
to sell which is not necessarily a mark
against the product but it doesn't mean
they don't know what to do with it now
it could be unusual a ballet or could be
unusual and good way but it is going to
make it harder for it to make its money
back it's also try explain the plot of
this thing right the premise to someone
who doesn't know it right you know and
who deeply like who the audience is for
the and the other problem is that you
say Stephen King and now it's a horror
film we right and it's not it didn't
actually now that I think of it Stephen
King's name has kind of been left off a
lot of the marketing I suspect without
exactly if it's social yeah and so this
so that's why I think that having that
framework is actually not as they could
get visited as it might seem I will see
if I'm gonna give them my money yeah
I've been reading suiting things I was
like 10 yeah a couple of months ago we
have actually the success I would have
bet money that this movie would not be
released at least not this calendar year
oh we have heard so little about it that
it just I was convinced that they didn't
know what to do with this thing but they
were having trouble but they were just
like they were supposed to be a trailer
that came out last October didn't come
out people who saw that it was bad there
was just a lot going on inside when this
movie if it might be released because
they sunk so much of money into it but
it's not very ton there that's even more
just to do reshoots and pick up some
changes so I am spread and always
something like the trailers out and say
hey it's coming out really soon okay but
you're ahead now of course we spent so
much time hanging on the marketing for
other movies being too much right now I
feel like one give us much of anything
in this moment but well isn't it there
is a balance to be out in terms of
drip-feeding of stuff that doesn't ruin
the most because as much as it convinced
me I didn't want to see the movie it was
because of my personal hang-ups so with
alien
gave us a pretty steady drip feed
trailers and material without laying the
plot route so there are ways to do it
I feel like Stephen King fans have been
clamoring for this for a long time or
not even people who are faced with his
other work but there is a whole
subculture playmate who just loved these
dark colors series and I've been waiting
for something like this if they don't
know that it's going to be pretty
different and it's not just an
adaptation of a first book but it's
going to borrow elements of the first
three or four books but not be in a
space and kind of like running almost
parallel an alternate universe version
of that type of story so if they're not
prepared for that the core fan base the
intended fan base for this might hate
the hell out of it as a GI Joe fan I'm
used to that a transformer sting yeah
moving on
the only other August release that I
have and I don't even have that much to
say about this but I put it on there so
we weren't only talking about oh boy
what else even comfortable it is no
artist that so far it's just dark out
not only wasn't each movies well the
only other one that I would like I don't
want only have one August movie on the
18th we have the hit man's bodyguard and
I don't even know so sequel to the hit
man there's some of it know what it is
oh wait no I think it's the movie
bodyguard the bodyguard I'm coming yes
from the prequel no no no although the
market he has run with it and had put
out a poster spoofing the classic
bodyguard poster though now it's stars
Ryan Reynolds and Samuel Jackson who's
carrying a cougar this is Ryan Reynolds
is carrying Samuel Jackson thank y'all
Darren does not look very happy about it
so this is this is an r-rated violent
buddy-cop antagonistic action comedy
thing and the basic premise is that Ryan
Reynolds is a prior bodyguard and he's
very good at it and he is hired to
protect um Samuel Jackson who is one of
the world's most notorious hitmen and
who has repeatedly
either attempted or succeeded in killing
people that Ryan Reynolds
and was attacking the bodyguard so there
passed across repeatedly over the years
but now he has to protect this guy hmm
who actually doesn't even want to be
protected and the first place because
these things he can take care of himself
I don't know that I think it's like he's
like state evidence or somebody like
that ledger but so you've got you've got
two violen guys who don't like each
other or move much right I'll be
shooting each other force to work
together yeah high jinks ensue and one
of them was white one of them was black
so okay okay well you sold me on at
least find a fellow down oh the direct
run this is a guy by the name of Patrick
Hughes oh yeah yeah he made the
Expendables 3 oh I found his main
directing credit that's kind of it he
hasn't actually I looks like he was a
second unit director hmm he's been an
editor like theoretically this'll be his
big break if it hit okay okay that's it
what sold me on it let's move along
we'll get back to Stephen King at on the
8th of September it yeah what it's part
one technically butter their their
dramas wouldn't - yes
they have yes the first movie I because
I don't know if you know the story if
you know even the book or the my
favorite okay the first movie is just
with their kids the second movie will be
just when they're adults that makes a
certain kind of sense except I don't
know anybody who doesn't agree that the
part with the kids is vastly superior to
the part with the adult that's what I
read it and it is yeah it's not even
close right but stuff where the kids is
so much more interesting so much scarier
and actually bigger like just he's just
doing straight page counts let's not
we're done with kids is if there were
anything left that people remember yeah
it's ugly and yes so the other piece is
that I think that it is probably as much
as I'd loved the work that has gone into
this home is I think it is probably one
of the best examples of something that
should not be done in film and that
belongs in a
like HBO or Showtime and should be
treated just seven seasons of you know
probably too much 96 episodes each
season happens to folks what five
thousand pages long and so it I it's it
and I think I think what you're going to
have is your order how we have a really
excellent personal and I said I think
the second one is well it ended and the
other problem is that the first one is
gonna make a lot of money yes and it's
gonna get watched a lot and it's going
to set up the second film or he's like
teetering kind of oh I'm you know if
that's what is the thing if they just
they don't need to worry about oh the
second thought was good they won't be
back for a third one because there's no
third one so okay maybe the second film
people come away disappointed but who
cares and stories them they've already
got your money I want this one to be
good because I really love the book I
wanted to be scary and even if it's even
if we only get half of it if this is a
good happen and I can feel like this is
its own kind of story like if I can
almost watch this in isolation and I'll
be happy as if this is successful and it
works it gives me a flicker of hope that
maybe someday the stands will be done
justice as well I think whether or not
the stand isn't because I mean if
there's any Stephen King story that is
too big for movies I think the stand is
one of them I think that's got to be
more dependent on the success of the
mist
TV series than it is on the release it
is interesting yeah the stand could be
an HBO series that basically goes
through season because the fade is three
books like it movie three movies again
you're on the problem where the first
book is the best but you could break
that up into three movies you could
break this like I mean they turn the
Hobbit in the three movies and they have
got two more for September on the 22nd
King's Men the Golden Circle I loved the
first one until the last
fifteen seconds of the film I love the
movie upside moment and I will
definitely seek civil and so I'm very
Dean for this because that first one
kind of came out of nowhere like a room
and this this has my interest to help a
lot more than say kick ass to did
because unlike that one where they
swapped director this one has retained
the same director whose name is now
something is he everyone yes thank you
who did the first kick ass and he did
x-men first class and action to my way
to think he has yet to make a bad movie
there's the nitpicky part of me that
goes I really hope they come up with a
really good justification for why Harry
still alive and it's not just oh well
the shop in killing cuz I'll be that
would bug me if that's all at it so I
hope that they have made a better
explanation than that but I'm game for
seeing him come back because Church
murder scene I never saw for fun yeah
okay so did everybody I know what I've
seen a few per se any Church burgers hmm
and I see the last 15 seconds okay cuz I
look what is this joke about what he's
talking about so okay so I'm absolutely
you see the movie pretty much so yeah um
again I would like to see the first one
before I see the sequel it's not high on
my priority but I [ __ ] around to
seeing it and I enjoy God like yeah I
had no problem I've danced a sequel
because everybody who saw it loved it
and they want to speak also yeah
it's funny in terms of in terms going to
release state it's a little funny
because normally I would think a movie
like this which is you know try it not
that the first one was a blockbuster but
it is trying for more that audience
getting released in late September I'd
normally consider that a red flag
because the first one got released in
February so obviously they are they saw
counter it work as counter-programming
last time and was the rated-r always are
now here's one Flatliners so I loved the
original one of you didn't eyeball guys
like it's nearby top ten movies of all
time oh great this is fun I have watched
that movie yeah I don't even know how
many times um and I think it was like a
first movie I bought on iTunes so I did
watch it digitally yeah I had it on
Betamax Wow
flatlining slide pull off fabulous okay
so they all remit you like you up and if
I remember correctly they have keeper
sublet isn't a he appearing the original
had very much a who's who up-and-coming
give herself at Chatham vacant right
Billy Baldwin Julia Roberts Oliver Platt
yeah this one has Diego Diego Luna okay
Ellen Page that bunch of people have
never heard of
so no Ypres Sutherland either in what I
expect to be a little more than a
glorified cameo if you're being honest
does it typically are they playing the
same services or we make up the same
story or that I don't know because I
don't know the character worse on a
everything they'll do they show Kiefer
Sutherland is listed in Nelson they're
playing the same character I don't know
I think something so that I somewhere I
read so I are we doing a sequel pseudo
remake name knows what I understood is
that it's a it's the characters thirty
years later and the story is picking up
for whatever reason so we're going to do
group of young med students are trying
to kill themselves something soulful one
guy who should be voted because well
it's so it's taking the Blair Witch
attempt to add X equaling basically
calling it felt the same thing but
technically being a sequel yes it least
that's mentioned again I don't
well I can't hear he is listed as
playing Nelson I'm gonna lose a little
bit of credence is one of those moves
you guys never gotten around to seeing
counsel we thank you for just a thank
you for the time you've spent without
the council is dissolving now I want to
remedy that but it's like so much very
80s it is if a nice Island is a Joel
Schumacher ad it was like he didn't walk
boys and this if I might drill shumar
grade I like walk more so lot so much so
that might be the favor of it is highly
stylized of the performances some of
them working up but it's okay I just
know I like that a lot
so so I guess that is it
it is there any part of you that is
excited about the idea of a remake /
revisit revival thing or is the only
feeling you've got now dread how close
are the Nazis to pushing yeah you can be
kind of Arab so I think that no we're
going to we're going to wrap it up
thanks so much guys who feels like
buckets on them well we are the
co-creators of the webcomic red and
green which is available Rising Sun
Comic Con presumably in the near future
it will be available in printed for you
to purchase I saw images of it but
beyond that I host Todd podcasts on the
fire mode podcast networks you can buy
the fire 105 back down days only I have
Nathaniel speed and which month you will
be appearing on an episode in the near
future
yeah a little tone and I read a comic
book Verizon Sun comics called armadillo
justice
it's about space overdose Freddy space
ants it's the best thing you've ever
grade well thanks so much guys and thank
you for tuning in if you're watching
this in video form you can listen to the
entire unedited version maybe unedited
or mic up at that big gap in the middle
um but nearly unedited version on the
council chief podcast is this recruiting
for Cape so thanks so much for tuning in
until next time this council is a jerk
[Applause]